what ha ha
all right everybody tense up
haha out of this the province [ __ ]
with me Tom
cameras on me now what the [ __ ] is the
line I forgot its maximum man Ellen have
some confetti should miss maximum
manipulates molecular allow her to go
for Oh would you like another one moving
on how the same thing that should happen
to you
psychological around Oh mother yep see a
smooth mother come walking towards you
Wanda vision is really hurt in the
feelings
hey youtubers is Charlie happy Friday
Captain America Civil War blu-ray coming
out these are the bloopers there's also
a whole bunch of other stuff going on so
yeah a Captain America blu-rays here
there's gonna be all kinds of deleted
scenes the bloopers you know which are
really awesome are actually surprisingly
harder to get on the blu-ray than the
actual movie if you guys didn't know
whenever they released bloopers for a
movie or for a TV show they have to get
all the actors that are in the bloopers
to sign off on it just in case they make
them look bad it's just like provision
in a lot of people's contracts but of
course most of these people have a
really good sense of humor so they're
like oh hell yeah you know put that up
there but they're just like stacks in
stacks of hard drives of footage that
they shot obviously there's a ton of
stuff that they could have put on here
that they probably didn't so it's
actually pretty hard to weed through and
find the funniest of the outtakes like
yeah okay fans will probably like seeing
vision almost-kiss Scarlet Witch it
almost looks like she's trying to slip
him some tongue there - maybe we'll
follow up on that infinity war the
funniest like one of the funniest
behind-the-scenes stories though about
them filming like any Avengers movie
that involves Iron Man is when they do
the heads-up display for Tony Stark and
you see Robert Downey jr. like in this
room here this is the way they do it now
but it used to be way more down and
dirty he used to have to lie down in
this dentist chair looking like he
talked about when he was doing the first
Avengers film with Joss Whedon he would
lie down in this like reclining dentist
chair with his face that was like
sticking through a hole where the camera
was pointing at it and Joss Whedon would
get up like real close to him and just
whisper lines into his ear and he would
just shout them up so like imagine your
friend shouting into your ear and you
just repeating them over and over into
this camera as you're lying face down at
a chair it kind of reminds you of a Ron
Burgundy thing where like he'll say
anything that's on the prompter but kind
of in keeping with that thing like all
the actors are really funny they're all
amazing actors but Robert Downey jr. is
actually really interesting in the way
that he changes scripts so he's one of
those actors I mean he's a very powerful
actor but there's this thing that he
does with directors that he works with
where he kind of works with the material
that they give him meaning that he has
the ability to change lines on the fly
like some directors don't like it when
you change lines there in the script
like they wanted to be exactly like the
script says one of the reasons why our
DJ Tony Stark is so compelled
is because he focuses more on the
emotion so when he changes lines like
he's really just trying to get to the
heart of the motion of a scene so he
doesn't get really bogged down with the
technical speak so if you ever wondered
why Tony Stark who's you know in the
Marvel Universe is supposed to be one of
these smartest human beings ever doesn't
do a lot of technical jargon it's just
because Robert Downey jr. isn't really
good with lines like that he's amazing
with emotion and that's like the most
important thing for big movies like this
so I'm always fascinated with how they
make the movies and the reason certain
actors work certain ways like all the
actors are different animals directors
have to do different things to get the
best performance out of them James Gunn
actually said something really cool
about working with Chris Pratt in The
Guardian so I'm going to post his clip
here what's a tip to get your actors to
do what you need I think really just
need to understand every actor is a
different person and they need a
different combination to unlock their
potential and so it takes a lot of work
to discover what an actor needs I think
it's another reason why I like working
with the same actors again and again
because I understand the actors that I
work with I understand the actors and
Guardians much better in vol 2 than I
did in volume 1 because it took me half
the movie sometimes to understand how
those actors worked so you kind of have
to imagine that a director on a big
movie like this is running a daycare and
all the actors are like his children
that he's trying to corral like he's
trying to get them to behave do what he
wants them to do if you've ever been to
like a big playground you see all the
little kids running around you can see
it could be kind of a nightmare if you
don't understand what each of the little
kids needs are so when you get the
blu-ray and you're watching the movie
again just imagine like a bunch of
little kids running around set with the
Russo brothers just chasing them around
trying to get them to performance scenes
but it's all amazing and when the
blu-ray does drop I'll do a breakdown of
all the deleted scenes there's a lot of
really good stuff that they put on there
but because it is dropping I'm upgrading
the give away so now it's going to be
for the value of the blue I think it's
like 30 bucks so the give away which is
normally like a $20 Amazon gift card is
not like a $30 Amazon gift card so all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so all the different Marvel
giveaways I do this week will be for the
equivalent of the blu-ray so get it--
make sure you guys check it out it'll be
a lot of fun what you got
wait for that to post you can click here
for my thor ragnarok behind-the-scenes
video you can click here for the flash
trailer I just posted thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight